dozens of people are outside right
behind me lying on hospital beds sitting
in wheelchairs waiting for a hospital
bed inside many of these people are
elderly they're sitting in the cold
it is rainy it is windy and these are
hong kong's most vulnerable residents
this is the situation indicating that
capacity is still a huge problem now the
hospital authority
they apologized for this very situation
saying they feel bad that this is the
circumstance but we are seeing it again
today indicating that indeed there is an
issue of uh hospital beds inside
these facilities now under hong kong's
dynamic covered xero policy they are
calling it
this is the situation this is the result
that is happened anyone who tests
positive for covid even if you are
asymptomatic even if you have mild
symptoms you are required to come to a
hospital or go to a quarantine facility
now in order to cope with the surge
authorities are looking at turning
student accommodation hotels and even
housing estates into quarantine
facilities but certainly the message
from beijing is stay on this no
tolerance approach to covet zero however
there is growing criticism of scenes
like this with many people saying that
authorities had two years to bring this
thing under control and to prepare for
an outcome like today and it's just not
good enough that old people are being
told to wait out in the cold in
conditions like this outside of
hospitals waiting for a space inside the
facilities